We've been doing a maid leave so. David had left. I i was at university and not in seventy three.
And it was the first term holidays when back when we had three terms rather than four semesters and the friends.
In down my name in the house i was sharing said.
We're all going on the trying to nimbin to not to which i sit and wait.
And it was part of the eye us which was destroyed in the student spliced in the university students.
Had arranged to try and call the good times express which went from sydney. Sorry from melbourne.
I think the bus students over from adelaide. And the train went from no been through sydney. And took about.
Seemingly five weeks. To get from sydney to to lose more than was stuck on busses and track down to nimbin.
And it was about eight thousand people here i'd never heard of newman i had never even actually been out of sydney much.
Up to that point and. That was my first real connection there and it's very hard to use lighted to explain the.
Well to illustrate the impact of that festival and.
The crush of the people and just the openness and spiritually just how wonderful it was through all of us boys
and girls who came from the suburbs and the unis. And then of course i went back to uni after that. As we all did.
And i came up at the end of that year. For a couple of weeks holiday.
Staying i've read you car which is just over the hill in the tweed valley.
And but those couple of weeks seems to have turned. Nearly twenty years now. So.
Well it largely was because it was based around the campsites of the people who you know. Formed in groups all of the.
The geography here. This festival was.
It was really interesting because it was sort of like de centralization in that they were camping areas.
All over the geography here in basically. People from their own mini hamlets. Within that within all of that and.
It was unseasonably. Fine and dry and beautiful all through the my.
Every day was hot and fine
and all the knots were were do we clear except for the full moon on which was actually a bit cloudy so for a change the
drop to the ground was dry.
But the town was a great big focus for all of the things that were going on throughout the time.
And i think just the fact of the people sharing in a zone.
And everyone's company on this large scale in a in a sort of a disorganized why we're also used to coming from.
Organized events and sporting events and sites live in certain cities but this was very very different.
And it was very much mike your own festival.
And for all of us had been to pop festivals and sundries and well life isn't things it wasn't.
It wasn't a rock star festival. They had the african. South african paying us dollar brand.
But it was very much an on ego situation in that even he was sitting on a little six inch high stage down in the
theater with a with an all piano want. And the bowls of bengal were there but they weren't. You know.
They weren't i see d.c.
or Ten years after woodstock when you think what was very prominent there i think especially with the religious groups.
All manner of seventy's. Surely this and bobber that who were actually a good deal more organized than.
Many of us who were came over they were sort of open. Open eyes and open hearts and open monster things.
And they were sort of the day within themselves had sort of a theatrical exposition. Musical expedition the singing.
And a performance thing that.
I think strongly touched trayvon as these sort of small professions would coming into town.
After dark and go into the hole and set up with candles and music
and sing this song of which you have a particular generally asen leaning that these religious groups had.
And the theater and the acrobatics of course who came in town and performed every not.
But to be very hard to say the name in festival was this or that all of these events happened
or these people did specific things because it wasn't like that at all.
It was very much this idea of do it yourself first of all it was like an hour of a cross between..
Between a boy scout camp and being on l.s.d. It's really you. Both of them strangely. This is something that struck us.
That i think in nimbin. And i think everyone. Because it has to be admitted the during that time a lot of the.
Solace or the mushrooms were taken. And so the whole. Impact. In.
You know not just visually and all related the team in six
and seven that night since is if you want to count that many was very very strong on people.
But i think the fact was and i've always felt that. And you got to say that mean than.
Even though i didn't know the truth of a den member in is in was the graveyard of one of the greatest forests.
Of red cedar that was ever known and it was called the red sea.
And even when we came here and a lot of these things are gone now.
But all of the hills and many of the messiah have gone. Had these the ring by a tree.
So the reminds quite tall you know fifty one hundred feet high. With you know the remains of what.
What limits they had up the top and of course they've been going on mushrooms. You had this. I did have this graveyard.
Feeling. And you could see a lot of erosion. In the hills around a lot of the slips and slides for him. So even though.
You got the ream of the trees in the forested hills around i mean.
It was obvious that this place had been had been cleared out. Lock stock and barrel. Of all this data.
And it was like it had been repapered with and. Darian and. Bananas and logs and things.
But there was a very much something missing from here and i've always felt that that. We're sort of here.
After the event so to speak. But then again in the twenty years that i've been here.
Many of these old bring back trees it was so apparent then.
Gone now been cleared or knocked out because the dam dangerous anyone. And of course in that time actually.
Because you go back to the time when they were briefed here
and you can actually be fined for having trees on properties
when big has the run of the die you know too many trees you'd be fined
and you wouldn't do well within the industry because it was clear everything as many blades of grass for the cales to
where it was what it was all about but that's changed a lot of a lot of the base has gone by the wind now.
And there are many more trees have grown back up in a lot of the people who've come in the intervening years of course
the plant a lot more. And so i think that's. It's made the place thing a lot a lot nicer. Now than it felt then.
Because there was this strange sort of ripened. Impression of i got from back then.
Much as i love being here and a lot more love to be out in the hills or not being a big boy scout in the carrier
and all those things and i've camped a lot i'm going to leave the bush. But i hadn't been to this area before.
And it you know it has that stripped. Eroded. Thing that.
It's sort of was in a real state of transition then because all the previous industries.
And the reason for their being had sort of folded. Because it's deliberate that you. Used.
Well i sort of kind for hold the die. Back at the end of that. I came to niman for holiday. The end of that.
University year in which the aquarius festival is on.
And i just as the group i was with who were a group of artists and musicians and sculptors.
We just suddenly realized that we were this. To house all this many community. With byelaws and berries and.
Igloos and. Tepees and. We just became this artistic. It wasn't a conscious decision really.
People were there for various reasons a couple had the house all others were visitors and people coming in
but we actually spend most of the year together on that point. And did a large exhibition in the sydney gallery.
And hogarth gallery through that here.
And started doing a lot of performances and and music
and i was a lost all i hadn't got into having been a good catholic boy in sydney and gone through university.
This was just a whole new opening up for me.
I started playing the piano when i was seven years old but most of that was in a formal academic sense
and i hadn't really got two or three or more expressive forms of music to.
Really that the evening that i came out here at the end of non in seventy three
and i haven't really looked back from that point up in musician and performer largely since then i thought. Oh here.
I've been writing poetry now for about eighteen years.
I think it was in the mid seventies i went down to adelaide for the arts festival
and i just was mixing with an old friend richard tipping the adelaide bicester powered.
And i just got involved with all the writers down there and.
I started writing immediately when i left there not through a lot of that time also. I was working in a way and.
That's quite a few of the people from nimbin it was a long period where for about five six years.
The number knots would go off and work the way to harvest that in the northwest of the state. Strangely.
At that time because we were not from the area. Which is why we originally got work out there.
Because there was lots of problems of. Potentials for corruption. With people going to. Grading.
Like a farmer's harley because you live there and it was very hard not to do with our mights the almight your problem.
And also which i found to be a good benefit of the toms a lot of the newman people didn't drink.
And once we stuck it on these are our lines out in a bleeding heart middle of nowhere.
Many of the our tuna workers that had in the past. Took to the drink pretty readily readily and radically and.
There was a problem the whole ship load of weight was turned back from china because it hadn't been properly tested in.
And so the number not so you know fifty or sixty of them would go there each year to work. But also was working.
Cotton harvest and and.
Fruit picking down on the mary and i just got into this of an acura of writing about travels and.
Working in may and then working harvests.
And then getting back home and starting to write more and more about nimble and the changes in the people
and just the color of the lack of color of things happening here as well. And.
In the late seventy's and early eighty's through the folk concerts and the variety concerts
and my classical music concerts and. Just the cafes a rainbow cafe and.
Other sort of event small and large interest of events and annual shows.
I just started performing more and more the power tree that i was doing and also getting in league with two
or three other writers up here. Who were or weren't writing about things local and. It just grew from that point.
To the extent now that we have regular we have shows called the grand piano
and poetry concerts where we'll have six power and six. Paying interests. But also run. Poetry events and all these.
More in bar and buy. And have a touring group as well. But a lot of that comes from. Just my own background i mean i'm.
I did. I did history at school i did. Anthropology at university so i sort of from mind this. This poet.
Anthropologist historian recording and.
Coloring or trying to do justice of the color of the things and the people around me here. So you think. Oh.
Many people came here many artists and performers have come to nimbin. Over the last two decades.
You know for many of the you know sydney brisbane melbourne. The capital cities.
But it's usually been a great diversity to them which i think as the time was gone on. This is.
This is being one of the magical things about the place here.
I think newman would have been very boring if you had you know two thousand people all saying bob dylan
and all cat stevens and not much else. But i think the diversity here. Of things here is that we are a rural community.
Whatever else newman might be it is that. Are slighted just by the geography of it. But it's you know.
Twenty miles to the nearest large town.
And the dumb as the musical
and artistic community here people became thrown together who in other situations in towns
and cities wouldn't have been put together. And that made the. Interesting crossover of. You know.
Indian percussionist playing with western folkies and. Kill to music i was playing with rock people and.
Kill think music is playing with regard. And just. I think the larger events.
And things like the name and all stars and the name and folk lab. Started rapping a lot of the.
The shoulders off the edges between the various performers. Such that. Now.
I mean the differences in the bed chemistries are always there.
And i grow too with the good things but i think it's got to a situation where.
Across the board a lot of these music goes and other people can work together. In situations you wouldn't imagine.
And also in the artistic situation where you can have.
For example had a recent spring arts festival where there was a lot of.
Arts crafts furniture woodwork ceramics jewelry and things on display but that was woven into a performance of.
Of ensembles baroque ensembles classical ensembles jazz pianists. Poetry readings. Everyone garde dance groups.
I mean to me i'm and speaking as the president of the newman school of arts incorporated. Which manages the whole.
I think these are the magic of events the big ones that really have the attraction for the public. And the community.
But also for the performers as well. And for the artist because.
They do these things on a large scar i like to do things on this sort of scale
but i think it it just draws people together on this bigger scale.
And it makes them also for your part larger part of this. Of this larger artistic community.
And gives them more respect.
I think in a lot of wise for what they're doing
and what others are doing because there is a chip on the shoulder bettany been.
There's a lot of clay shows that the media. Readily fall into about anyone and. I think it's very easy to carry that.
Like a clock around you was well rather than to say you were once the ones i'm worth.
I mean it's ludicrous to my mind to point to the village like nimon inside that place has got a drug problem.
When the whole world's got a drug problem. Or that place has got a problem with our tuna and so on and ploy people.
Whereas it just seems to be a bit of a hive into these people and where they are all over the place.
From the coast and land anywise. Just into the finger.
Gets pointed to it in a bad way and i think the media is not helped a lot of the artist to feel.
You know how they step back from that whereas i go back to the outside well now and. On a nimbin performance part.
And that's what i do. And i find that. There's a fascination i go to sydney or melbourne.
And there's an absolute trust and i shouldn. About. Nimbin and. Any anthropologist historian poets. Words about newman.
I don't know what it is it's like. It's like the daytrippers. I mean newman's got a bad reputation in many wise.
And yet. During any holiday period. Devolve hours in the commodore was in the day trippers with their world to do.
White noise on. Reebok to. Jacuzzi families come out here on mass. Every holiday period.
I don't know what they are trying their attraction is i can say why i come here.
I don't know where they come for a bit of a day or i think in a bit of a. A bit of fun.
And it's a bit shocking to some of them but and.
It's somewhere between shock in korea also do you in a man's life cheaper than going to calcutta or or.
If you're staying in byron bay do a day trip to nimbin and. Go back home feeling.
Rest assured in your mortgage and they are spec in sydney or melbourne that you've got.
It's a strange thing some people come here expecting the worst in a very quiet here
and other people come in are actually open minded and. And think it's is wonderful sort of smorgasbord.
Pot pourri of things going on here. Pretty much everywhere from you know.
Doctors are not all or some people within speak badly of nimbin and.
Don't like the clichés about it and some people were very defensive of their town.
But i think most people when someone comes in has only been here for twenty minutes and a cup of coffee and.
And bad mouth the place before they're in their car driving or why. I don't think anyone really likes that.
But i think also we're a bit. World weary. Just with the necessity of. The obvious spare.
Front page headline which just. Points things in one wise.
One why because i think what's really got to be stressed is that newman is a very complicated place.
It's not a one dimensional place at all. It's a very complex place.
And i really think the best and worst of people come here and the best and worst of things happened here.
And it's almost a nightmare of it. There is a certain.
There is more than a certain there's quite a degree of tolerance. Of other things.
But of course within that this great deal of intolerance. But i think that's always been very apparent here.
Is that there's a very diverse. Lot of people of come here just like the y.
Eaves of people have come here the original hippies the whole influx of.
Sort of newcastle lots that came in the light seventy early eighty's and the how.
What you'd have to call sort of yuppie a step bush family.
Four wheel drive people actually came here with money and property and.
And plans even if all those players didn't match their expectations. But there's been many stages of. Of changes.
Just like right now in not in ninety two going to ninety three there's a great deal of china is in development an
expansion systems and recycling the garbage and running but power companies and. Perma culture developments.
The expectations around how all these things will go i think is a bit.
I don't think i think it's a big question mark in many people's eyes about what's going to happen.
But then again i'm going our look around this.
These hills in this bowl shaped valley we're in here
and i see this is going to be quite a city here in twenty years time.
Whether we like it or not just by a crush of population alone.
And by the attraction of the fact that people keep pouring in here.
With their yuppie day trippers with people looking to get out of the city looking for a lane.
Whether they're the german backpackers. You know. It just comes and comes and it comes all the time. Because there's.
It's what you call a person. In some wise a sense we have to prove it.
As souls but of course there isn't any acoustic thing in nimbin other than earth to prove anything.
And the rest of the world's pretty stuff to any why.
So i mean they can't really come around pointing fingers here when everything else is such a mess a messy elsewhere.
But neumann's been very very sort of quintessential even.
In the home builders in the forest actions and many other chinese in hand birthing.
Lots of things that actually stem from that that have had influences in some ways.
A large influence in other areas apart from here.
But even the new perma culture developments if they come out anything like the ideal.
These are really important aspects that. That have a larger effect on australian culture.
Nimbin audiences can be very very tough audiences.
Especially for the fact that so many people have performed here in so many groups from you know. Maybe trippy cosmic.
Religious people. Findhorn people. Slim dusty. All sorts of people have come here. Dance groups overseas groups.
Theatre groups. One man shows.
A lot of people and i think it's a bit of a testing ground for many performers and theatre groups and.
Music those who are on tour.
Going up the eastern coast are heading for brisbane or festivals in queensland or whatever and i think our name
but what we can always do is showing nimbin but neumann's had.
You know there's an attitude in him and you know i've been there seen that done that and.
I mean you've got to promote things already hook into things to attract people to things because so much does happen
here. And human is a bit world weary.
And of course the recession is bodying as deep as anywhere else and there are a lot of.
There are a lot of poor people living in this area. Much as i'd like to be in a time in even coming forward.
To keep the car going to get to the end of time and little loan to pay to get in the door. Around.
This first poem i wrote in the summer of not in seventy seven. And it's called.
It's a tip always a poem is a better name and this is called the holy and the oldie and the oily tao. We are.
But praise and blame. Said stephen. Of the famous found. To know right of reply. Save each day's. Words.
Or love or lack all along this line from. Musically gumboots. To house. Couse the slaughter. Intense.
We reshuffle the deck. Of choice. And chance. Rather ruled by. Meetings and encounter. Then. Would we trust leaders.
For no one could be everyone. Thus. Stalking simplicity. Through complexity. Count. Just count. Contrary to contrary.
For ever diverse our ways we spread out spontaneous. Structure. Survival. Vs creativity. Alone. Versus children.
And what point of balance twixt all this. Never still for long enough of everything rainbow.
And zodiacs do you rush this town along the way side. The real estate sign reads fast food. Country.
So often blind to the song of the slow. Creeks and rivers of moon walking the night sky. And breeze.
Invaders to the land way. Just like the others. And black men gone. And forest gone. And he'll slide away wrinkled.
Fall and fall. And the valleys sing. Of pieces torn or why. We invade. And next of course. We invaded by technology.
Man ploughs. The time. We invade ourselves. We invade ourselves. But all settlers eyes.
Trace only the figures ever walking the one street. So many drifters and buy in arms and barefoot.
The colors in the clothes and the crazies. Wrapped in blankets and.
Mud to for shoes and dreams of guitar blues or heroin do you use the past of the ol shadows.
And which way shall we be in this. Painted. New mythological. Town. And some many yet to come from womb or wheels.
Or wondering why. Open or closed. Which way shall we be wanting to be fair and fine and friendly.
Yet not flooded by the highway. Flow and peace in the valley. And peace at home.
To blend and be in feel freedom not to have icky. Trying this last notion of primitive touch. Of trust and trials.
Of community. Not to ninety five. Fly. Night at rainbow's brained. The one rule. In the town. Is the right to rule.
The moral is let it slide i from pub. To rainbow half. Across the village street.
The bandage hands during tea with a serene and stays the only safe place. And stage type tonight. The d.
Frocked swamis corey haim. Says he is drunk. Dance raging for all out on the floor.
And looking up from the world of east he cries e i guess he flies on the hundred other eyes in the room
and the rush of the show into overload. And number two mad eyes. Unwashed for a week. On the sly.
And none going to even hold his eyes. To ask is nine. So alone and so much pain for all. A word or conned.
Or company again. Melting into the corners. And the night rocks on.
And wrecks some the ben jamming too fast and slow but holds the feel of friends. And the fights tonight.
And the night rocks on to the midnight hour.
Out the door and down the hill into the borrowed veranda bed limb still pumping and mind. Counting on the drums.
Shifting sleepless across the name been i. The town rooster crows on the hour. And from cox chorus.
Up the valley to old sun rise. Where it comes through the sheets. And the village stays back with another face.
For every day. With mother wheat and mother child. Father free. And roof.
Does droop and the fall and people are planted like we. It's in the power. And high. Day.
Out of town and diode is easy. Over the miles. Back to the house. Above the sea. Into sanctuary and slowly.
A potted history. Of a day. In the life of newman. And it came to pass on the eighth moon. Of the seventy second year.
Of the twentieth century of the most. Published. God. That the conservative government. That would not conserve. Fail.
And the house of god did rule the land of milk and wheat and sheep do. And they did give the new year.
To the vietnam war. And they did fly on wein's of. Petrel. Their troubled sons from the jungles of blood and.
Fear and herbicides. Back to the beer. And bosom. Of their suburbs. But for many the bosom had withered on the created.
Card of desire. And the cake. Of ambition and career tasted of toxin. And cason and gin and boredom. Of a sudden.
Did flow from the river. Of the aquarian jug. Scouts and ambassadors of dunster men allen and peter stuyvesant.
Who did come upon the village of nim been in the valley of malcolm in the dark i have shattered trees
and slaughtered beef and banana spray and braved the feudal lords. And the scouts did call. And trumpet.
Through the land. Of this company. Of rainbow power. Of this one alternative why.
That coursed and co all their clans from the towns in the cities smoke. And those are ponderous. Mushroom.
And slept face first in the dark. It was a band of gypsies playing in the rain.
And they gave the see to each other and they filed. The government of papers.
And they moved in cars and vans and sandals and barefoot. And bare breasted. Upon the land. Some came running. Gladly.
Or madly been changing names. And colors. And gods. Changing the gods. Into grass castle kings and herbal flings.
And a free flight of raining forest. A moon dance of market. Days are flood. And fire and frost. The cascade of sleep.
The bursting of by the. Over the hills. Of the far away. Tree. And in the time. They turned to find the tweezers.
To tug at the tick. From the tip of their dick.
They had children and children's children that grow a coat of many colors about them.
That waxed in the old wave of their waning aquarium. Waters. That wash. And feed the.